le drapeau ukrainien flotte à nouveau à
rubis ce n'est celui l'âge fait partie
des dernières communes libérée par les
forces du craignent haine dans la région
de karkhiv région pilonnées par les
russes depuis le début de la guerre et
qui voit enfin la menace éloignés
les forces armées de notre état nous ont
donné de bonnes nouvelles de la région
de karkhiv les occupants sont
progressivement repoussés de cette zone
mais dans le donbass les troupes russes
ne relâche pas la pression et selon le
commandement ukrainien elles frappent
également sans merci la région de
nicolas yves dans le sud ouest du pays
il s'agit du dernier verrou avant la
ville portuaire d'odessa centre culturel
majeur tant pour les ukrainiens que pour
les russes le renseignement américain
créé un conflit prolongé avec un risque
d' escalade
la guerre est de nature incertaine et se
transforme en une guerre d'usure il faut
ajouter à cela que poutine fait face en
décalage entre ses ambitions et les
capacités militaires de son pays cela
peut probablement signifié que dans les
prochains mois la situation pourrait
évoluer vers quelque chose de plus
imprévisible
selon l'institut américain d'étude de la
guerre l'armée ukrainienne pourrait
probablement avancer jusqu'à la
frontière russe dont les jours ou
semaines à venir